you can't make dairy out of nuts I can't
cows and nuts are different I'm like a
convenience vegetarian straight-up
meat-eater we did a bacon taste that's
the other day and it was the happiest
time of my life
it's got no lactose no casein no gluten
no soy no cholesterol yes I don't know
what else could be in this doesn't look
too bad so far it says it melts and
stretches why do I have to be told that
it's gonna melt and stretch already
smells funny I'm starting to
second-guess it now the smells coming in
oh that's not Swiss cheese oh yeah
really tastes like cheese oh yeah it
does really bad I have goose bus please
and what and like mucus on a sandwich I
can imagine this going really well like
that yeah well unlike a meat sandwich
doctor cow tree nut cheese hi I'm not
feeling well it's doctor cow available
doctor cow is a very funny name nuts
like I didn't know you could aged nuts
this is a candle someone just forgot to
put a wick in it someone took a
lifetime's worth of earwax and like
compounded that's exactly what it looks
it's really gross okay so this actually
has a more cheese like feel it smell oh
man that smells the diabolical it smells
like kind of sour this one's way better
than the last one no it isn't I'm so
upset to say that it works I think this
one's way better it's still a little
mealy and weird
it really doesn't taste like any sort of
cheese but it's not bad
it has hashtag cheese Karma so look at
this label it says follow your heart
liberal packaging really pisses me off
I am with you it even feels like cheese
like feel this it's like got like oh I
got that bout smells
[Music]
nah oh oh no oh the consistency is
terrible aftertaste wasn't bad though
like it's you know have a trampoline
feels like if you took a bite out of
that that's what this would be yes zero
out of ten
tofutti I love these names man this is
like my favorite part oh you don't know
Joe foodie I don't know - oh they make a
whole line of ice creams and other
shitty dairy products it's actually this
smells the most promising it tastes like
the real stuff yeah I feel like you
could fool me with this I think it would
taste much worse hot though I could eat
this whole thing
that's pretty unoffensive treeline
cheese trina cheese aged artisanal tree
nut cheese you could probably put this
in someone's bathroom they wouldn't like
wash their hands with it you know that
brand Crabtree and Evelyn they make like
candles and like soaps it was like
play-doh
it looks like play-doh it feels like
play-doh I feel like if Urban Outfitters
sold cheese this is how it would be
packaged this is very pleasing cheese
it's not bad yeah I mean this fancy
cheese is working out they made tree
nuts tastes kind of like blue cheese
this is fun to play with okay for Keith
and capered Hilary so this is artisanal
vegan cheese from a shop in Los Angeles
for mosh for more so vegan for Maj it
looks nicer than the other one
sounds kind of douchey oh yeah I can put
this on everything oh man oh yeah I like
it oh yeah yeah yeah I could do this
mm-hmm they'll never get the texture
right I think we just have to accept
that this is a sweet little girl let me
taste more of that what were those two
bites like a dollar fifty of cheese this
like opened me up to like a whole new
world I think I'm gonna stick to milk
cheese we've come a long way yeah and
vegan cheese we've got a long way still
to go we have such a long way to go I
wonder if all this vegan cheese is gonna
make my poop look weird